let's have some fun miles shall we
with the gentleman
who hijacked
the entire
2021 draft start to finish he hovers
over it holding his cocktail glass
either with scotch or tequila depending
upon his mood either neat or on the
rocks maybe with a stone or two aaron
rodgers and
it happened so fast yesterday
it really did and it does feel to me i'm
curious to get your take on this
it felt orchestrated to me did it feel
orchestrated to you
well i i think it did if for no other
reason because aaron rodgers doesn't do
anything by accident right when he
started talking about oh my future is a
beautiful mystery that wasn't an
accident um when he who's you know come
out and said these different things that
you know my future here is not up to me
those are things that he says that i
believe are very calculated look it's
very calculated and you've been pointing
this out all the time like that he is
really going hard
after being the jeopardy host to replace
alex trebek so
aaron rodgers doesn't seem like the kind
of guy
that would do anything by accident that
would leak anything by accident so yeah
i mean whether the timing happened to be
because it was basically the first year
anniversary of the packers trading up
for jordan love and basically starting
that clock for aaron rodgers time in
green bay throughout maybe that had
something to do with it i don't know but
it just certainly seemed to me that yes
there is some sort of calculation going
on here for why all of this stuff is now
coming out about aaron rodgers
and it's not all that difficult to
figure out what his plan is if it indeed
was planned and i think we both agree
that it was you give the packers until
the draft to do what
to take care of his contract in a way
that would provide him with the kind of
security that he doesn't currently have
the packers have been trying to preserve
the year-to-year existence with aaron
rodgers if he slips we go to jordan love
we trade him we go to jordan love we
have that power we're going to use it
and we used it in 2020 and oh it
motivated aaron rodgers to become the
league mvp
maybe next year it'll motivate him to
become the super bowl mvp again let's
continue to dangle the carrot while we
also hover with the stick and we get him
in that sweet spot where he's mad enough
to play great but he's not so mad that
he comes in and he starts
throwing things and creating a fuss and
wanting out well the problem is they
pushed it too far because now that he
doesn't have the kind of contract that
gives him the certainty and also
i remember when donna mcnabb was benched
in 2008 there was a report after that
season that he wanted a financial
apology from the philadelphia eagles for
what they had done in benching him for
kevin cobb in a late season game against
the baltimore ravens and i feel like
for rogers miles
the contract isn't the root cause
of his dissatisfaction it's a symptom
of it and it's a it's a path to a cure
because through a new contract
they can show him the respect
and also create
a situation where they are bound to him
by the way the contract is structured
fully guaranteed payments over two or
three years for example cap charges that
would make a trade impossible to
accomplish almost put them in a position
where they'd have to flip jordan love
like the patriots had to flip jimmy
garoppolo
and
that's kind of where it is right now
where the contract effort fell apart and
now it's
i want out and we haven't heard from
aaron rodgers we have heard from brian
gouda coons surprise surprise football
team says we're not going to trade a guy
how many times have we heard
a guy from a football team say we're not
going to trade a guy and how many times
do they turn around and trade the guy
after they say they're not going to
trade the guy
almost a hundred percent of the time i
feel like that's what happens right like
that's gay precursor to the trade we're
not gonna trade him that's one of the
boxes you check
yes i remember saying uh les sneed when
like 2015 deleting sam bradford's not
the answer two weeks later they trade
him for nick foles right dave gettleman
saying we didn't just sign odell beckham
jr to to trade him away and what do they
do they trade him to the cleveland
browns so yeah it usually does seem like
the precursor to the trade but i think
the interesting thing about this is you
know if you're talking about aaron
rodgers and feeling disrespected it's
it's basically like the packers made a
bet right and you know they were trying
to get rogers in the sweet spot or
whatever it is but they also were
basically betting that either rogers is
going to be transcendent maybe and
they'll help us win the super bowl this
year or and this is what we probably
feel is like is more likely he's going
to continue to decline because they sort
of thought that he was declining in that
first year with matt lefleur now i don't
necessarily get that i mean it's not
like they didn't make the nfc
championship game did they play all that
well in the nfc championship game no but
san francisco was really really good in
2019 so you make that trade up you get
jordan love and i think you're basically
betting hey rogers is going to continue
to show that he's falling off and we are
justified and then saying yeah jordan
love is going to be our guy because you
guys can all see that we're justified in
getting rid of aaron rodgers in some way
shape or form that bet has totally
backfired because now i mean aaron
rodgers just won the mvp they were a
true blue super bowl contender and for
whatever reason they weren't able to get
things done in that nfc championship
game against tampa bay fine but you
still have a team that has been two
back-to-back nfc championship games and
you've still got aaron rodgers and i
think it makes a ton of sense for rogers
to not feel loved if that's the way we
want to go about saying it because he
has clearly continued to elevate this
team and mike i thought you made a good
point in something you wrote today that
rogers is the most important person in
the organization because they don't have
owner oh if he's an important person in
the organization
they need to start acting like it
and that's the fundamental
nature of the impasse here one of the
things i'm going to write later tonight
during rounds two and three so i'll
manage to stay awake for the full four
plus hours
and i talked to a gm about this
yesterday and this concept has been out
there this isn't anything revolutionary
but the idea that football players are
starting to act like nba players where
they're in control of their careers
they're in control of their futures
regardless of what their contracts say
and that butts up against the old school
football guy mentality of
you play for us you just work here you
don't tell us what to do we tell you
what to do you sign a contract honor
your contract you have no leverage we
have the leverage play for us play for
no one and the indications are at least
for now that that's what the packers
intend to do with aaron rodgers now you
can maybe pull that off with a position
player it's hard to pull it off with the
quarterback if the quarterback truly
doesn't want to be there we went down
this road with deshaun watson just a few
months ago before deshawn watson's world
dramatically changed the idea that if
the quarterback doesn't want to be there
it's one of the reasons why the bears
didn't try to trade for carson wentz he
didn't want to be there you don't want
someone
at that position the most important
position on the team who does not want
to be there and the packers continuously
have treated aaron rodgers like a
blue-collar worker when he truly is a
white-collar worker we say this all the
time at least i do you can't expect the
quarterback to be the guy who is
the person who holds teammates
accountable shows up early stays late
studies films grinds and sets the
example and does all that stuff
necessary to lift the team
and then when it's time to treat him
like he's a member of management say hey
just go punch your time card and we'll
worry about running the business and i
think that attitude has always been
present with aaron rodgers by virtue of
the fact that they traded up last year
to get jordan love they're planning for
life without aaron rodgers so he is
planning to seize this situation
and he is and we'll see how it plays out
because
this may be and i saw ian rappaport
point out earlier today the idea that
david dunn is roger's lawyer and david
dunn was the one who
was involved with carson palmer when 10
years ago he essentially quit on the
bengals and the bengal said go ahead and
sit and it wasn't until an opportunity
arose to fleece the raiders that carson
palmer's career restarted well if that
opportunity didn't arise two days before
the trade deadline carson palmer would
have been out all of 2011 and then what
happens in 2012 who knows that's what
aaron rodgers may be looking at because
i think the packers miles far more
likely to treat rogers the way that the
bengals treated palmer you want out too
bad we have a contract with your name on
it and we want you to honor it
i i find it really interesting that
that's how they're going about it and
there's a part of me that really
understands why
i'm just from the management standpoint
look you have one of the greatest
quarterbacks of all time and he's under
contract why would you want him to just
be able to let himself essentially
choose no i'm done here and and this is
the way it's going to be and then i'm
going to help pick my destination i get
from their standpoint why they don't
want to do that but i also think it's
interesting if you just look at the last
couple years and these top guys that are
quarterbacks and what's kind of gone on
around the league it's more and more it
seems like there are just a lot of guys
a lot of veteran guys who are starting
to get disgruntled with the management
situation and they're not always under
contract i mean tom brady is obviously
the greatest example of this he leaves
the patriots he goes down to tampa bay
and he wins a super bowl you can look at
somebody like philip rivers right he
leaves the chargers after decades there
and then he decides he still wants to
play he goes to indianapolis and then
they make the playoffs matthew stafford
another guy he doesn't want to go
through another rebuild so he helps them
engineer a trade to the los angeles rams
i mean it's very interesting right i
mean you brought up carson wentz but
that's another guy that didn't really
want to be where he was anymore so they
facilitated a trade to get him out so
it's just interesting to me right now
what is going on with all these
different qbs and how they see
themselves and how they feel like there
is some power that they can use and then
use this leverage that they may or may
not have in order to start getting what
wanting starting to be where they want
to be
at some point this weekend i'm going to
write something that looks at all the
teams that tom brady has screwed up
psychologically by what he managed to do
last year by going to tampa bay and
winning a super bowl and the packers are
on the list the 49ers i think are on the
list because they could have had tom
brady and i think this desperate move to
go up and get trey lance or whoever they
were going to get before they took true
lance trey lance what was was a reaction
to the fact that they could have had tom
brady and they they decided not to that
brady wanted to play for them and they
said no thank you and look at what they
could have had so the packers the
seahawks the 49ers there's probably a
few more that have been screwed up by
what tom brady did but with roger
well the patriots obviously and look
what the patriots are doing now they're
going all in because why tom brady's
coming to town the prodigal son is
coming home and you're going to be the
fatted cat that gets slayed when he
shows up with his new teammates because
his team's better than yours right now
which is one of the reasons why they
went out and spent all that money in
free agency but
with roger's contract because i think
that ship has sailed now i think that at
this point they're not going to give him
the kind of security that he's looking
for under this threat under this sense
of duress
i'm told
that it wasn't just security he was
looking for he was looking for
what objectively he deserves best player
in the league should be paid accordingly
accordingly sims and i have said this
multiple times 33.5 million a year for
aaron rodgers that's jared goff money
that's carson wentz money that's a slap
in the face to aaron rodgers
he
now look he'll have plausible
deniability because he's not the one
doing the negotiating but
the highest paid quarterback in the nfl
was on the table at one point now that
may have just been a negotiating point
and you work off of that but it's not
unreasonable for aaron rodgers to want
to be the highest paid player in
football and that definitely would have
created a situation where the packers
were found to aaron rodgers and that's
how
you show him
that you have seen the light
sorry aaron rodgers we screwed up last
year we shouldn't have drafted jordan
love that was wrong we value you you've
been loyal to us for all these years
you've said time and again you want to
finish your career with the green bay
packers that means a lot to us we're
going to pay you accordingly and oh by
the way we don't have an owner into
whose coffers the profit flows so we can
go buy a super yacht 70 million in
profit last year for the packers it just
goes right back into the business well
why not pay him 45 million dollars plus
one to put him ahead of patrick mahomes
that was their chance that chance has
gone and i don't think it's all that
controversial that he would have wanted
to be the highest paid player in
football he was the best player in
football last year
oh certainly not certain certainly not i
look i mean he is the guy that many
people at least
i've seen many people i'll at least
speak for myself he's the guy that i
thought has been the best player to ever
throw a football until patrick mahomes
came along right and so i think
especially when you see what he did this
year he still has it you know and he's
still i think got some really good years
left of football left in him so when
he's going out there and he gets that
second year with his head coach and he's
more comfortable in the offense and he
understands the things that they're
trying to do that much more and he's got
guys that he's so comfortable with like
devonta adams out there it makes a lot
of sense that rogers was still playing
at this high level and so i think that
if you're the packers it's almost just
hard to admit that you made that kind of
mistake you know that you should not
have traded up to go get this
quarterback that you couldn't even use
as a backup last year and i think that
that's something that's kind of
important to remember look jordan love
was not the backup qb they know nothing
pretty much about how good or bad jordan
love is and if you've got this much of a
mystery and now you have aaron rodgers
out here talking about the things that
he's well he's not talking about them
leaking the things i suppose we should
say that they have been leaked over the
last couple days this is a huge mess
especially like i said you just don't
know what jordan love is and you tried
to do this thing with this bet and it's
not working out for you and i don't know
how you solve that i really don't
yeah and
i i was told yesterday that if they do
trade aaron rodgers the idea is they go
forward with jordan love and i think at
this point they have to see what they
have in jordan love after they gave up
what they gave up to get him and also
sacrificed the ability to get guys that
could help them get to the super bowl
and win it last year you have to see
what you have in jordan loft but who
knows what they have in jordan love and
it's okay to admit you were wrong it was
okay to dangle and betrayed him it's
okay to say we're all in with aaron
rodgers we made a mistake the worst
thing you can do when you make a mistake
is double down it feels like the packers
are more inclined to double down than
they are to mend fences and so here we
are what happens rogers could retire he
would owe 23 million dollars in signing
bonus money that he's yet to earn plus
6.8 million roster bonus that he earned
earlier this year sometimes the payment
comes later so they just wouldn't pay it
to him but he's looking at almost 30
million dollars to walk away
that's a lot and he'd give up 14 million
in salary this year if he doesn't play
that's not insignificant you have other
fines and punishments if you do stay
away if it comes down to it and he does
what deshaun watson was believed to be
ready to do with the texans it could
happen the jeopardy angle is out there i
want to run this one by miles because we
exchanged the text message or two on
this point
one of the reports floating around out
there and i think it came from me in rap
report the idea that hey rogers can just
go host jeopardy and walk away well it's
awfully presumptuous
isn't it
to throw that out there i know aaron
wants it
he he's not bashful about saying so but
it's very presumptuous to just assume
you're gonna get it
and at what point do the jeopardy people
look at this and say number one we
really don't like being pawns in the
middle of this
back and forth between rogers and his
team it's unseemly number two
you are being a little presumptuous here
aaron we haven't offered you the job yet
number three
we see how this relationship
between
employer and employee is unfolding for
rogers and the packers
may not be an employee that we want
to deal with for the next 20 or 30 years
because if the packers are having these
issues with this guy
who's to say we're not gonna have
issues with this guy and i hearken back
to a comment that shireen williams made
yesterday that i won't repeat verbatim
but
i will it's kind of like well but what's
what's the what's the
uh the the the saying is
and and i you know it's
it's the word where you can say both
hazard you can say ass and then a few
words later you can say hold
if you run into one of those people
you've run into one of those people if
you run into one of those people all day
long you're that person so
if you can't get along with one person
there's somebody that you can't get
along with you can't get along with
anyone
you're you're the
you're the one
yeah well i i believe what shireen said
and i agreed when she said it yesterday
i was watching the show that he doesn't
even really get along with his family so
how are they really expecting
to be able to get along with him and i
think that that's now somebody tweeted
this too you know he this guy probably
doesn't seem to talk to his mom very
much and you think you're gonna win a
standoff with this guy if you're the
green bay packers it's probably not the
best idea but i do think that you are
absolutely right that they're being a
little bit presumptive right now this
whole oh he can go and host jeopardy
who's to say that he has been the best
jeopardy host that's been out there
right i mean hasn't now ken jennings
been sort of the favorite to take over
for alex trebek throughout the entire
thing and i know that they're going to
continue to get more people in there
throughout the summer burton is another
guy that's been really campaigning for
this thing for jeopardy and now he's
going to get the opportunity to host it
we'll see how good he is with this so
yeah there's no guarantee that aaron
rodgers is absolutely going to be the
host of jeopardy whether or not they
think they're going to bring in a new
audience i mean it was cool to watch
aaron rodgers on there for a couple days
and i think i maybe watched two or three
episodes but that's not going to make me
tune into jeopardy just because i want
to see aaron rodgers like that the
people who watch jeopardy are going to
watch jeopardy i don't think you're
going to bring in that much of a new
audience just because aaron rodgers is
there
look everyone's going to take the high
road and say all the right things but i
will suggest something here and i don't
know what actually happened but when
you're there for three long days day of
rehearsals stressful anticipation etc
day one
five shows long ass day stress etc next
day long ass day at some point at some
point
they're gonna see your best at some
point they're going to see your worst i
don't know what they saw but my my point
is this
to get back to what you said it's
awfully damn presumptuous to just say
well i'll just go host jeopardy and i'll
retire okay
we should probably talk to the people
from jeopardy before we come to that
conclusion and again the people from
jeopardy may be watching this very
carefully saying
hmm let's see
didn't get along with this didn't get
along with this remember when they did
the 60 minutes profile
and one of the storylines was he's
really sensitive and his teammates were
making fun of him and then he complained
about it and 60 minutes issued a
statement he's proved our point he's so
sensitive he's sensitive about being
called sensitive so that's just reality
and i know that the packers fans out
there still blindly loyal i don't know
how much longer that's going to last but
still blindly loyal to aaron rodgers and
uh and miles to kind of put a button on
this it's at the point now where this
guy has to tell us what he wants he's
not afraid to tell us he wants jeopardy
he needs to tell us what he wants
professionally it's getting a little
ridiculous it seems a little childish
come out and tell us what you want don't
give us beautiful mystery don't give us
ambiguity don't don't go on any program
where you're going to be treated with
kid gloves sit down and talk to somebody
who's going to ask you real questions
and give real answers that's my request
of aaron rodgers
i think that aaron rodgers will go on
what he wants to go on and then he wants
to say what he wants to say which is not
going to be very direct and i know i i'm
agreeing with you because look i don't
think it's going to be clear and direct
it's going to be this stuff that he can
has done years and that he's going to
continue to do and then he'll just say
that he doesn't like you when you
interpret his words
and just like he's done so far in the
draft the aaron rodgers storyline has
hijacked the first segment of the show
today
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports